Welcome back everyone this is my new spider-man
no way home video marvel just dropped another new
big preview in empire magazine featuring a whole
bunch of the sinister six characters basically
confirming the roster there's a couple new scenes
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're also doing a giveaway for movie
tickets all you have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber and post all your sinister six theories
on the video but recently you probably saw all
over your feeds all these images from this empire
preview that just dropped i literally just did a
spider-man no way home video about another preview
they did with doctor octopus scenes most of the
additional scenes that they also released this
morning feature dr octopus heavily because they're
kind of trying to hold back as much as possible on
everyone else and they just showed huge scenes of
alfred molina's doctor octopus in the last trailer
so there's not really any point in them trying
to hide him anymore which is why you're seeing
so much of him in all these brand new previews
but in the new preview they did confirm the
rest of the official multiverse sinister six
roster and it wound up confirming my theory
from my first big spider-man no way home trailer
video i'll link that below in the description
that last trailer was pretty obvious with
which members were on the team there were
one or two members that people weren't quite
sure about but this new preview just clarifies
that a little bit more here you can see they
state the team is actually the sinister five
technically is alfred molina's doctor
octopus willem dafoe's green goblin
and thomas hayden church's sandman all from the
tobey maguire spider-man movies so that's three
then jamie foxx's electro and rhys
ephon's lizard from the andrew garfield
amazing spider-man movies so when i say there was
one or two characters from the first trailer that
people weren't totally sure about there was the
scene of somebody swiping tom hall and spider-man
or trying to swipe him from the darkness in
doctor strange's basement of the sanctum there
my big theory is that it was probably lizard
but some people thought that it could have been
someone else this preview basically just confirms
that it was lizard and because it's called the
sinister six not the sinister five there are
reports of other sinister six characters being
referenced during the movie but not featured
the same way these particular five members are
including michael keaton's vulture and maybe a
name drop of the apology moddy rhino but i don't
think that rhino is going to be anywhere in the
movie because he was such a laughing stock during
amazing spider-man 2. i don't see how anyone
brings him back unless it's as a huge joke
and for the most part in all the footage that
we've seen everything that everyone said the
director tom haunt all the other actors most
of these multiverse sinister six films they're
playing in the same tone as they like the
same raimi spider-man movies the way they
played horror and comedy in the same breath
like all the tobey maguire spider-man movies
had a very specific sense of humor with
the way they played all the villain scenes
you getting on my nerves i have
a knack for that not anymore
there were jokes but they always did a good job
of balancing the jokes in the horror elements so
that you still took the villains seriously like
they did feel like a real threat to spider-man
during the movie the scene that everybody points
to when they talk about this and it's a perfect
example is a doctor octopus on the operating table
with his arms just completely destroying everybody
it's like give me a spider-man movie but make it
evil dead or army of darkness and that's just sam
raimi's sense of humor if you've never seen any
of sam raimi's classic horror movies like evil
dead army of darkness be sure to check them out
because they are classics and they'll give you a
good idea for the way they'll play the horror and
comedy elements of doctor strange too multiverse
of madness because if you weren't aware sam
raimi is currently directing doctor strange too
kevin feige said it's like bringing the mcu full
circle because he was originally a producer on
the sam raimi spider-man movies when they were
making those so kevin feige has been working
with sam raimi on marvel stuff for the past 20
years so it was kind of like bringing him home
in some of the new scenes that they released
as part of this preview they also dropped some
teasers so in this brand new scene here of doctor
octopus going after spider-man it says spider-man
no way home isn't just a sequel it's a massive
meta multiverse outing in which peter parker
finds himself fighting iconic villains from past
lives notice the confirmation villains from past
lives as in multiple villains multiple sinister
six films in past lives isn't meant to be a
reference to reincarnation or anything weird like
that or the notion that toby maguire spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man existed inside the
main mcu timeline they're not trying to make any
crazy references to he who remains king and loki
the way he manipulated the timeline trying to say
that they existed in some previous version of
the sacred timeline they're using the term past
lives as more of a shorthand reference to those
original tobey maguire spider-man movies in the
andrew garfield amazing spider-man movies like
past lives as in past versions of spider-man in
the real world since because in the movie they're
treating each different spider-man franchise of
movies as its own separate universe obviously that
includes the venom movies too but they're mostly
talking about the other spider-man franchises here
like toby maguire and andrew garfield are from
completely different universes separate timelines
per the loki rules of the multiverse which are
now like the canon rules for how the mcu marvel
multiverse works each of the different spider-man
sinister six villains from the different
universes that come to the mcu because of
doctor strange spell are also coming from points
in their timelines right after the endings of all
their previous movies so alfred molina kind
of confirmed this for him the last thing he
experienced would be sinking down to the bottom
of the east river with his fusion reactor and for
jamie foxx's electro the last thing he would have
remembered was fighting andrew garfield spider-man
and amazing spider-man 2 and being dissipated so
much that they believed that he was dead side note
2 science lesson you can't kill something that's
pure energy it only gets converted to other kinds
of energy so even though doctor strange's spell is
responsible for bringing all these villains back
with a twist electro wouldn't really have been
perma-dead in the amazing spider-man universe
they also released a preview of a new scene here
of spider-man in the newer advanced suit without
his mask on inside the sanctum the background
structures and architecture look like the
basement room that he and doctor strange performed
the spell in and this is also supposedly where
doctor strange traps the multiverse sinister six
villains before peter accidentally releases them
like in this trailer scene you literally see
the now confirmed lizard from amazing spider-man
swipe at him from inside this makeshift magical
prison and obviously this is a very familiar scene
of doctor octopus crushing tom hall and spider-man
with his arms he's wearing his iron spider suit so
if you couldn't tell they're still on the george
washington bridge so this is all part of that same
bridge fight scene from the trailers and i say
familiar because it looks exactly like scenes of
him crushing toby maguire's spider-man head during
many different spider-man 2 scenes just gonna pop
that head right off like he's an action figure
and if it wasn't clear from the last trailer
scenes doctor octopus's arms his coat his whole
outfit are meant to be exactly the same as they
were during spider-man 2. the only reason why they
seem a little bit different is because when they
brought alfred molina back because it's 20 years
later they used a lot of special effects to de-age
him so because the technology that they're using
to film him to present him on screen the texture
of his skin his hair his coat just look a little
bit different but it's meant to be the exact same
as it was during spider-man 2. like i said it will
be as if no time has passed for him at all since
the end of spider-man 2 and it's the same for all
the other sinister six villains as well i think
the way they're explaining elektro's lightning
being yellow now like if no time has passed for
him why is his lightning now a different color
i think the idea is that kevin feige wanted to
be more comic book accurate with him thus the
yellow lightning but the way they'll justify that
is they'll just have him absorb some other kind of
energy that's different color and that's why when
he's fighting spider-man later his energy gives
off a different color for those of you also asking
about green goblin because it's a little bit
harder to explain him coming back because he died
in the same timeline of doctor octopus and if he's
grabbing doctor octopus from this point in time
shouldn't green goblin be dead they're using
doctor strange's spell in a really broad kind of
way so if you never read the spider-man one more
day storyline mephisto basically does what doctor
strange is doing now like he causes all these
changes to the timeline by basically swapping in
replacing bits of it with other timelines other
universes mixing and matching aspects of other
realities to change the main universe and during
spider-man no way home doctor strange's spell is
pulling in random bits from other universes of
the spider-man franchises but also doing it from
random points in the timelines of those alternate
universes so that's how he can grab doctor octopus
green goblin and sandman all from different points
in the tobey maguire spider-man universe timeline
because all those characters existed during
different parts in the timeline and when the
spell is doing that effectively what it does is it
saves those characters from dying like the spell
steals all those characters from different points
in their timelines right before their deaths so i
think part of the idea with the no way home title
is that it's also meant to be a reference to the
concept that the sinister six characters believe
that if they did go back to where they came from
they'd all die so they can't go home like they're
meant to be stuck in the mcu for now also spoiler
warning for the venom let there be carnage post
credit scene if you haven't seen that movie yet
because that's kind of relevant to what's going
on with doctor strange's spell and the multiverse
and pulling all these villains from different
universes is basically the same scenario with
venom coming into the mcu in the venom let there
be carnage post credit scene eventually he will
probably find a way to go home and they'll do more
venom sequels without tom hall and spider-man but
they'll end the movie with a way to explain how
they can continue to have multiverse crossovers
with all these different characters and other
potential characters from those other spider-man
franchises in the future if they want so everybody
post all your reactions in the comments below just
all your sinister six theories let me know what
you think they're gonna do with the sixth member
of the team i'll leave the giveaway open for a
couple days i've got a couple other big marvel
videos that i'll be posting so make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so you don't
miss anything everyone click here to learn about
those other brand new scenes of doctor octopus
in spider-man no way home and click here for my
venom let there be carnage post credit scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!